En tant que géologue, ça me passionne,
mais la Terre est belle,
puissante, dynamique en évolution constante.
C'est un lieu de vie fascinant.
Je veux partager avec vous mon point de vue de géologue :
comment comprendre l'histoire de la Terre
renseigne et guide nos décisions actuelles
pour mener un mode de vie durable sur Terre.
Il y a de nombreux phénomènes intéressants sur sa surface.
Zoomons sur l'image.
Je vais vous parler d'un de ces phénomènes.
La matière est en permanence déplacée sur la surface terrestre,
et en particulier, les hautes montagnes s'érodent,
leur matière est transportée, déposée dans la mer.
Ce processus se déroule en permanence
et a d'énormes répercussions sur le paysage
Voici un exemple dans le Sud de l'Inde :
ces montagnes sont parmi les plus hautes du monde
et vous voyez sur cette image satellite
des rivières qui transportent de la matière des montagnes à la mer.
Ces rivières sont comme des bulldozers.
En gros, elles prennent ces montagnes et les poussent vers la mer.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Zoomons sur l'image.
Je vais vous parler d'une rivière.
Vous voyez les beaux motifs que dessinent les rivières
en poussant la matière vers la mer,
mais ces motifs ne sont pas immuables.
Les rivières ondulent et se déplacent pas mal,
et peuvent changer nos vies.
C'est ce que montre l'exemple de la rivière Kosi.
La rivière Kosi suit un cours régulier en demi-lune
elle sort des grandes montagnes du Népal
chargée de beaucoup de matière,
des sédiments venant de l'érosion des hautes montagnes,
et se déverse sur l'Inde
en déplaçant cette matière.
Donc zoomons à cet endroit
et je vais vous raconter un peu l'histoire de la Kosi.
C'est un exemple du dynamisme de ces systèmes.
Voici une image satellite d'août 2008
colorée pour que la végétation soit verte et l'eau bleue.
Vous voyez bien le cours de la rivière en demi-lune
quand elle sort du Népal.
Voici son cours pendant la mousson.
Août est la saison de la mousson dans cette région,
et quiconque vit près d'une rivière connaît les inondations
et les risques et inconvénients qui y sont associés.
Fait intéressant, en 2008,
cette rivière s'est déplacée de manière très différente.
Elle a créé des inondations inhabituelles.
Donc la rivière Kosi s'écoule ici,
mais parfois en emportant des sédiments,
les rivières s'embourbent,
et ces bouchons poussent les rivières
à complètement changer de cours.
Cette image satellite a été prise juste 2 semaines plus tard.
Voici l'ancien cours de la rivière,
qui est en demi-lune,
et vous voyez que ce n'est plus bleu.
Désormais, il y a un autre chemin bleu
qui traverse le milieu de l'image.
La rivière Kosiest sortie de son lit.
À titre de référence, l'échelle est de 65 km.
Cette rivière a brusquement bougé sur 50 km.
Elle était bouchée et est sortie de son lit.
Voici une image prise 1 semaine plus tard,
et vous voyez les anciens cours
et constatez que le processus se poursuit,
la rivière s'éloigne toujours plus de son cours principal.
Vous imaginez que dans de tels paysages
où les rivières se déplacent régulièrement
il est très important de comprendre quand et comment elles évoluent.
Ce genre de processus se déroule aussi près de chez nous.
Aux États-Unis, presque tout le territoire continental constitue
le bassin versant du fleuve Mississippi.
Il pousse de la matière
depuis les montagnes Rocheuses et les Grandes Plaines
Le fleuve charrie cette matière à travers les États-Unis
et la déverse dans le golfe du Mexique.
C'est le cours actuel du Mississippi,
mais il n'a pas toujours coulé dans ce sens.
L'étude du profil géologique
permet de reconstruire son cours dans le passé.
Par exemple, cette zone rouge ici
est l'ancien lit du Mississippi, là où il déposait de la matière
il y a 4 600 ans.
Puis, il y a environ 3 500 ans,
il suivait le cours souligné en orange.
Et il a continué et continue de bouger.
Voici le fleuve il y a 2 000 ans,
il y a 1 000 ans,
700 ans,
Ce n'est que récemment, depuis 500 ans,
qu'il occupe le cours qu'on lui connaît aujourd'hui.
Donc ces processus sont très importants,
particulièrement ici, à l'embouchure,
où les débordements de lit du Mississippi se produisent
et accumulent de la matière à la rencontre entre terre et mer
C'est un territoire très prisé,
et ces deltas sont parmi les endroits les plus densément peuplés de la planète,
donc comprendre la dynamique de ces paysages,
leur formation et leur évolution future
est très important pour ceux qui y vivent.
Les rivières ondulent aussi.
Des déplacements plus grands que ceux dont on parlait.
Je vais vous montrer des ondulations de rivières
Envolons-nous pour le bassin du fleuve Amazone.
Ici encore, on a un vaste système fluvial
qui s'écoule des Andes en creusant de la matière des montagnes
et la charrie à travers l'Amérique du Sud
pour la déverser dans l'océan Atlantique.
En zoomant, on voit les cours sinueux du fleuve.
Ce sont de beaux chemins, mais ils ne sont pas immuables.
Ces rivières ondulent.
L'imagerie satellite nous a permis depuis 30 ans environ
de suivre leur évolution.
Prenez une minute pour observer n'importe quelle courbe
et vous verrez qu'elle ne reste pas au même endroit bien longtemps.
Elle change, et son cours se redessine.
Regardez cette zone en particulier :
il y a une sorte de boucle dans le fleuve.
qui est complètement coupée.
Presque comme un coup de fouet
qui se sépare du cours du fleuve à un endroit.
Là encore, juste pour référence,
à cet endroit, le fleuve a changé son cours sur 7 km
en 1 ou 2 saisons.
Donc les paysages que nous habitons sur Terre,
à mesure que de la matière s'érode des montagnes
et est charriée vers la mer,
ces paysages ondulent
et changent tout le temps,
il nous faut comprendre ces processus
pour vivre dans ces paysages de manière durable.
Mais c'est difficile avec pour seule information
ce qui se passe actuellement à la surface de la Terre.
Nous n'avons pasbeaucoup d'observations.
Nous n'avons des images satellites que sur 30 ans.
Plus d'observations sont nécessaires pour mieux comprendre ces processus.
De plus, il faut comprendre
comment ces paysages réagissent au changement climatique
et aux changements d'utilisation des terres
quand nous continuons d'occuper et de modifier la surface de la planète.
C'est là que les roches interviennent.
En s'écoulant, les rivières
charrient de la matière des montagnes vers la mer,
et parfois du sable et des roches restent pris dans le sol.
Cette matière qui reste dans le sol est enterrée
et avec le temps, des couches de sédiments
s'accumulent et deviennent des roches.
On voit donc des endroits comme ici,
où il y a d'énormes empilements de roches sédimentaires,
et nous remontons dans le temps
pour voir les paysages du passé.
Cela nous permet de reconstruire
et de comprendre l'évolution des paysages sur Terre.
C'est aussi pratique,
car la Terre a une histoire plutôt hors du commun.
Cette vidéo-là est une reconstruction paléogéographique
des 600 premiers millions d'années de l'histoire de la Terre.
Un petit bout de temps.
Donc, avec le déplacement des plaques
on sait que le climat et le niveau des mers ont changé.
Il y a beaucoup de types de paysages différents
et de milieux différents à explorer
en remontant le temps,
si on avait une machine à remonter le temps,
et oui nous en avons une,
car on peut observer les roches déposées à l'époque.
Je vais vous donner un exemple
à une époque particulière du passé de la Terre.
Il y a 55 millions d'années environ, un réchauffement soudain s'est produit,
parce que beaucoup de dioxyde de carbone
a été libéré dans l'atmosphère,
ce qui a provoqué le réchauffement rapide et extrême du climat de la Terre.
Par chaud, j'entends très chaud.
Il y avait des crocodiles et des palmiers
aussi loin au nord que le Canada et aussi loin au sud que la Patagonie.
C'était une ère chaude qui est arrivée soudainement.
Donc nous pouvons remonter le temps
et trouver des roches déposées à cette époque
puis l'évolution du paysage selon cet épisode de réchauffement.
Ici, hourra, des roches !
(Rires)
Donc voici une pile de roches
cette masse jaune ici,
c'est le fossile d'une rivière,
comme dans ce graphique,
ce sont des dépôts qui remontent à 55 millions d'années.
En tant que géologues, nous pouvons les examiner de près
pour reconstruire le paysage.
Voici un autre exemple.
La masse jaune, c'est le fossile d'une rivière.
En voici une autre au-dessus.
Nous examinons en détail, faisons des observations,
prenons des mesures de caractéristiques.
Par exemple, les caractéristiques soulignées ici
nous indiquent que cette rivière avait environ 1 mètre de profondeur.
Vous auriez pu traverser ce joli ruisseau à gué
il y a 55 millions d'années.
La matière rougeâtre au dessus et au dessous de ces bandes,
ce sont des dépôts de sol anciens.
Leur étude nous renseignerait sur la vie à cet endroit
et sur l'interaction entre ces rivières et leurs plaines d'inondation.
Donc ces observations permettent de reconstruire avec précision
le cours des rivières et l'aspect des paysages.
En étudiant cet endroiten particulier
à cette époque-là,
ce qui est arrivé avant le brusque réchauffement,
les rivières ont creusé une voie des montages à la mer,
quelque chose comparable au bassin amazonien déjà cité.
Mais au tout début du réchauffement,
les rivières changent du tout au tout.
Soudain, elles s'élargissent,
et commencent à s'étendre davantage sur le paysage.
Plus tard, les rivières sont retournées à un état semblable
à leur aspect d'avant l'épisode climatique,
mais il a fallu beaucoup de temps.
Nous pouvons remonter l'histoire pour faire des reconstructions
et comprendre l'évolution du paysage sur Terre
selon des épisodes climatiques ou l'utilisation des terres.
Certains modes de changement des rivières
ou les raisons du changement de leur cours et de leurs déplacements,
résultent de choses telles qu'un surplus d'eau à la surface du sol
quand le climat est plus chaud,
donc plus de sédiments sont érodés.
Tout ça change le comportement des rivières.
En conclusion,
tant que nous vivrons sur Terre,
nous devrons gérer les ressources et les risques
qui découlent d'un milieu de vie dynamique.
Je crois que la seule façon de le faire de manière durable
c'est d'inclure de l'information
sur l'évolution et le comportement des paysages dans l'histoire de la Terre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)